اهلا بكم لا خلاف على ان ازمه الطاقه كانت
من بين العناوين البارزه التي تصدرت
المشهد بشكل كبير هذا العام اندلاع الحرب
في اوكرانيا واشتداد الصراع بين روسيا
والمعسكر الغربي ادى الى ازمه طاقه حقيقيه
اسراع بين المعسكرين تسبب في شحح امدادات
الغاز والنفط ما ادى الى ارتفاع الاسعار
في الاسواق العالميه تطورات ادت الى وصول
سعر الغاز عالميا الى رقم قياسي عند 345
يورو لكل ميجاوات
كما شهد العام 2022 دخول السوق العالميه
للحبوب ازمه حقيقيه ايضا فقد ادت الحرب
الاوكرانيه الى توقف عمليات تصدير الحبوب
الاخرانيه ما اثر على السوق العالمي وتسبب
بازمه غذاء على مستوى العالم
ارتفاعه اسعار الطاقه فضلا عن ازمه الغذاء
والتضخم وارتفاع الاسعار فجرت موجه
تتظاهره واضطرابات في الكثير من دول
العالم خصوصا اوروبا التي دفعت فاتوره
باهضه احتجاجات طالبات برفع الاجور ونددت
بارتفاع الاسعار في بريطانيا مثلا تشهد
البلاد حتى الان سلسله اضرابات تاريخيه
شملت اربع قطاعات حيويه في البلاد وهي
الصحه التعليم النقل والمؤسسات الحكوميه
كما شاهدت البلاد لاول مره في تاريخها
اضرابا لنقابات التمريض شارك فيه 300,000
ممرض وممرضه في عمومي بريطانيا طبعا
شهدت فرنسا ايضا اضرابات وقبل قليل شهد
قطاع الطيران في بلجيكا شيلنا بعد اضراب
لموظفي شرطه رينز
[موسيقى]